c'est une amie accusés rejugés pour la
croatie pour la saison 2010 qui se
retrouvent sur les bancs de la
conversion en avions déjà condamnée à 2
2 enfants déclare toujours innocent sûr
que j'aurais également rouler en citroën
cyril maintes fois pour des lignes
aureilhan un visage d'adolescent
l'homme qui se présente devant la cour
d'assises dès mineurs à 31 ans pour la
troisième fois en 13 ans il fait face à
des jurés populaires
patrick 10 apparaît détendu décontractée
une sérénité
une confiance qui affichent également
ses parents le procès de lyon ne doit
pas être une répétition de ceux de nancy
et de reims je ne vois pas tous les baux
témoin qui a eu sa
je comprends mais maintenant c'est pas
un problème
les parents et les grands parents des
deux victimes préfèrent pénétrer dans le
palais par une autre entrée dans la
salle
leurs visages sont sévères grave ce
troisième procès est une épreuve dossier
n'a jamais plus refermer la plaie
toujours béante puisse de ville quinze
ans pour la cc de parler de ce dossier
alors effectivement c'est une épreuve
terrible pour lui quand tout ce matin le
public attendait de pouvoir prendre
place dans la salle
présent en prétoire les deux députés à
l'initiative de la nouvelle loi le huis
clos peut désormais être levés quand
l'accusé est devenu majeur
la démocratie n la gagne est la
publicité des audiences et je me réjouis
de la presse représente à ces
plaignantes ainsi qu'au public parce que
je crois que c'est un facteur démocratie
patrick disent qu'ils s'expriment
publiquement pour la première fois sa
voix est douce et déterminée il évoque
le double meurtre de montigny-lès-metz
comme une affaire très grave
madrid 10 ce matin essuyé sa première
déconvenue à lyon sa remise en liberté a
été refusée
la cour ayant rappelé que par deux fois
il a été jugé coupable